I'll be the first to admit not every
make sure make ends up being correct and
maybe not every theory is your favorite
or maybe you're just sick of my puns and
non-stop meme references well today I'm
gonna do something about it I want you
to think of everything I've ever done
that you didn't like that Star Wars
prediction a grown worthy dad joke
whatever comes to mind now focus on it
got it
great now if you'll just do me a favor
and look right here
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
protecting the world from the scum of
poorly cited research so after suffering
my way through bright on Netflix widely
hailed to be the worst movie of 2017
which it's not not by a longshot but it
did provide me some great out of context
lines such as fairy lives don't matter
today and you know what they say once
with the dark Ward always the Dark Lord
I decided to take a trip down memory
lane to revisit Will Smith's well maybe
not his better early movies but I at
least liked him a lot when I was growing
up and first up on the nostalgia trip
was men in black back from the time when
Will Smith couldn't decide if he was an
actor or a rapper sometimes he was bald
[Music]
if you called wild wild west rapping or
acting that's what I do
anyway men in black gave us the
neuralyzer a device that with one flash
makes you forget practically anything
except the fact that the mitochondria is
the powerhouse of the cell that one is
locked in there
I'll let Tommy Lee Jones explain how the
neuralyzer works this is called a
neuralyzer this red eye here will
isolate the electronic impulses in your
brains and more specifically the ones
for memory everyone looking at the light
gets zapped their memories of what
they've just seen get a raise and the
agent replaces it with a different
memory with a lot fewer aliens cool so
it's a sci-fi gadget big whoop right
well we've learned a lot about memory
since this movie first came out 20 years
ago and I'm telling you right now the
neuralyzer has gone from a creation of
science fiction it is something we could
totally make today never had deja vu
how do you know the real men in black
haven't already neuralyzed you in the
deja vu is just you experiencing
something that was wiped from your
memory the first time long story short
in order to make a neuralyzer we need to
establish three things one that memories
can be erased two that false memories
can be forced into people's
and three that it can all be done with a
Porsche light so get ready because here
comes the man that won't let you
remember your childhood the same way
ever again see I can't wrap either Will
Smith you're in good company
sorry point number one can memories be
erased I mean we've all heard stories of
being unable to form any new memories to
determine who killed your wife so you
tattoo Clues on yourself instead of
writing them down on paper like a normal
person but is it plausible that we could
wipe out specific memories of things
that we had just seen it turns out the
answer is a solid yes and it comes from
a place you might be surprised to hear
on a channel that prides itself on
science I'm talking about hypnosis but
not the kind with some spinning spiral
thing that makes you think you're a
chicken or makes you want to subscribe
to the film theorist channels subscribe
to the film theorist channel subscribe
to the film theorist Channel I'm talking
about hypnotic induction which is a real
therapeutic technique to get patients
into a deep state of relaxation which
increases theta waves in their brain you
know you get all your great ideas in the
shower well it's because relaxing in a
shower results in a high concentration
of theta waves which makes connecting
otherwise disparate ideas in your brain
awful a lot easier this also applies to
memory but theta waves can also be used
against you and hypnosis here is the key
lasting memories that you'd otherwise be
able to recall for instance and this is
nuts
last year Samsung released an online
hypnotherapy tool called unspoilt that
walks you through a self hypnosis
session that's supposed to help you
forget movies and TV shows so you could
watch them again as if you're watching
them for the first time
closure I had Chris from our team do it
and yeah he still remembers the red
wedding but he's recently been overcome
with this strange urge to buy a phone
that spontaneously combusts no but all
jokes aside after going through this
treatment he could no longer remember
how the series ended whether he had even
seen the series end in the first place
even the main character's name and first
ridiculous as that might seem the
science behind it is actually a hundred
percent solid in 2007 scientists
published a study in which they showed
participants a movie then hypnotized
them to try and make them forget it
when they tested the group that had been
hypnotized the subjects couldn't recall
details of the movie that they had just
watched maybe they should have just had
hypnotists outside of the emoji movie
that's 90 minutes of my life I'd like to
forget anyway the people who had been
hypnotized could remember where they had
watched the movie and other details
surrounding the experiment but they
actually couldn't remember what happened
in the movie itself and it's not like
they were just forgetful either they
actually demonstrated different kinds of
brain activity from a control group that
wasn't even ties this kind of isolating
amnesia is exactly what we see
demonstrated and men in black when
normal people come into contact with
aliens the men in black don't just wipe
the person's memory completely instead
they isolate one element of the memory
just like the film study did and they
replace that memory with something else
which of course brings us to our second
question can you really implant false
memories into someone's brain and yet
again the answer is yes it's actually a
lot easier than you might think
a Canadian psychologist named Julia Shaw
has demonstrated that when people are
asked about their involvement and events
that never occurred their memories will
actually start to form versions of that
fictional scenario and the people will
eventually believe that it happened
here's dr. Shaw telling one of her
subjects about a completely fictitious
event so the other event was your cancer
forecasting was when you're 14 years old
you initiated a physical thing in the
place of your parents
girl responds pretty much exactly as he
would expect from someone who had just
had a story made up about him I don't
know man I gotta say Canadians are so
polite even when they're calling people
liars
anyway fast forward just a few minutes
in this interview and all of a sudden
the same woman suddenly has memories of
the event all the psychologists had to
do was provide a framework for the event
get the subjects to try and remember and
suddenly their brains fill in what's
missing from the memories which is of
course everything the memories weren't
there to begin with
Sullivan is also situational here the
subjects are likely influenced by a
desire to comply with an authority
figure asking them questions but that's
exactly what would be happening if you
met the men and black in real life now
of course I can see your
counter-argument here sure these false
memories might be implanted but it's not
like they're gonna stay in anyone's
memory or be trusted for any length of
time and yeah that would totally make a
lot of sense if it had any bearing on
facts false memories run rampant even in
situations where our memories matter the
most like say when you're testifying at
a murder trial you ever heard of someone
wrongly convicted of a crime being
exonerated by DNA evidence well
statistically that person was probably
convicted in the first place because of
a false memory according to the American
Bar Association and astounding
three-fourths of the cases overturned by
DNA evidence relied on eyewitness
testimony for the wrongful conviction oh
yeah that's totally the guy I saw killer
well DNA evidence proves he was in
Hawaii sorry you missed out on years of
your life buddy now imagine for a moment
that you've just come to the realization
that aliens not only exist but walk
among us on earth because you saw
something absolutely bananas go down and
then some very calm in charge look in
person in a great suit shows up and
flashes something in your face and tell
you that you didn't see what you really
thought you saw even if the neuralyzer
was just a flash of a Polaroid camera
here are pretty likely to walk away
believing what they just told you all
right Matt Pat cut the BS
you're probably saying right now enraged
by my suggestion that your memory is
about as reliable as a cable company
showing up on time
these examples you're giving me are from
carefully controlled experiments that
took place over long periods of time
sure you might be able to force people
to forget things or remember things that
never happened but you can't do it
instantaneously with a flashlight are
you sure about that because scientists
have already done it oh yeah loyal
theorists the future is here hope mr.
meeseeks opto genetics is a new branch
of neuroscience that enables researchers
to control individual neurons through
electronic impulses directly into
people's brains it's pretty complicated
as one might expect electronic mind
control would be but here's the gist of
it scientists can modify the genomes of
mice to be particularly sensitive to
certain kinds of light and they can also
map the areas of the brain that are
stimulated when the mice is experiencing
something that would form a good memory
like when it's eating food or when it's
in its home in this clip right here a
mouse is put into a bright box with no
hiding place and it responds with fear
response
it's powering in the corner it's scared
of this new environment right but once
they flashed the light into the mouse's
brain they basically turned on a switch
that activates the good memory and
suddenly the mouse starts moving around
the box like it's cold turn the light
off again and the mouse stops
immediately dead in its tracks turn it
back on and it's grooming itself like
its back home turn it off again and well
you get the idea now granted Mouse
brains aren't human brains but as we
explored with Dan Harmon in the pickle
Ric episode they're structured similarly
enough that in a few years this could
easily get transferred into the human
brain it also proves Ches assertion at
the beginning of men in black that the
light from the neuralyzer is enough to
enter up signals in the brain and this
kind of on/off switch effect from
memories actually coincides with what we
see in later movies in the series in men
in black 2 we find out that memories
that have been neuralyzed can be brought
back so it's not so much that they're
getting deleted as they are getting
switched off so it would make sense that
in black have developed a kind of
optogenetic technology that can activate
certain parts of the brain and shut off
others instantly with a single remote
flash of light so there you have it the
neuralyzer is physically possible but in
order for it to be practical with
near-future technology it would mean
that every single human being would have
to be genetically engineered to be
sensitive to certain kinds of light and
then also have transponders implanted
into their brains to receive the signals
that were sent from the neuralyzer x'
but in the men in black universe that's
definitely what's happened the entirety
of New York City is neuralyzed by the
Statue of Liberty's torch at the end of
men in black - so we know both that
everyone is susceptible to this
technology and that the men in black
have engineered the world to keep their
secrets under wraps with all the alien
technology they have access to it
doesn't seem like too big of a stretch
to say that they're putting chips in all
of our heads and as long as they keep
neural izing us along the way we won't
know the difference
in fact who's to say that we don't have
chips in our brains right now and that
we've all forgotten the memory because
we've already been neuralyzed but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut
[Music]